What do you think is the correct answer, David?
>> So on the left, we have the same two frames we had in the first problem.
So first, I thought that the circle in the middle disappears, so
the triangle should disappear.
But none of these options match that.
So then I went back and looked and
said, the other way we can think about this is to say the circle on
the outside disappeared but the circle on the inside grew, since their both
circles we can't really tell the difference between those, but once we
know that the correct answer is not just the big square, we can say the only
logical conclusion is to say that the square disappeared, and the triangle grew.
So the answer has to be three, the big triangle.
>> That's a correct answer, David.
But notice something interesting here.
This is an example of generate and test.
You initially generated an answer from it and
then tested it against the choices of a level.
Yet the test failed, so you rejected a solution.
And you generate another solution.
For that one, the test succeeded, and you accepted it.